désormais maurice papon est un condamné
en cavale les magistrats de la cour de
cassation pris plus de temps que prévu
pour rejeter son pourvoi avant de
constater qu'il ne s'était pas constitué
prisonnier et qu'il était désormais en
fuite
aux yeux de la justice compte-rendu
dominique verdeilhan et patrick voix
papon déchu d'abord un timide bravo puis
quelques applaudissements
viennent ensuite les larmes des victimes
papon ne s'est pas constitué prisonnier
hier la cour de cassation refuse donc
d'examiner sur le fond le pourvoi déposé
par l'ancien ministre
conséquence la condamnation à dix ans de
réclusion criminelle devient définitive
pour les victimes c'est un soulagement
juives qui ont été déportés parce que
vous êtes tués
il n'ya là on leur donne une idée qui a
le rôle auteurs il aurait pu être
emprisonné nourrir dans huit jours ça en
aurait fait un martyr
moi je 13 heures
très heureux comme ça le trouve que
c'est une fin à laquelle lui-même a
participé par sa lâcheté
voilà a condamné il revient désormais au
gouvernement de faire exécuter la
sentence prononcée au nom du peuple
français
maintenant aux autorités françaises les
six française de retrouver la personne
qu'il n'aurait jamais dû laisser filer
on nous a bien cherché à nous avec des
faux papiers on nous a trouvé en arrêter
mon père alors pour mettre 20 euros la
décision de la cour de cassation
justifie le choix de maurice papon est
ce que vous confirmez l'information
comme quoi on vous aurait dit qu'il
était indésirable en suisse
je le confirme et regarde je n'ai rien à
dire je ne m'occupe pas de ces questions
est ce qu'une demande en de graff
l'envisager
voulait pas répondre m
pas de réponse sur la demande de grâce m
e varaut a décidé de se tourner vers la
cour européenne des droits de l'homme à
strasbourg